noise from the crowd and we had a little  bit of a tussle here between Brewer and  Harden  now they're having words Brewer is  driven the league a long time I mean  let's face it he's former teammates too  [Applause]  he's not gonna get in hard his head and  he's still talking to him we had TJ  McConnell trying to talk to her now the  official  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  to rule  now herd manure  Harden's got three here's the dunk my  Brewer gets right into the chest of  James Harden no no come on man  and number one how can leave our  Richardson Paul bat and he was all the  way at the other end Mike Micallef was  he was on the call right here I'm  surprised at this at this one what  Brewer looks like Gumby doesn't even  like arms omits justify it arrive when  he's getting minutes right